hello i'm matthias from datatec
and this video is about
hypotheses and hypothesis tests
at the beginning i would like to
explain to you what hypotheses and
hypothesis tests are finally i would like to go
into how hypotheses
are integrated into the research process
then i will come to you  types
of hypotheses there are and explain to you
what the significant level is and the
probability and finally
comes the highlight and that is how you
can easily calculate hypotheses online directly in your web browser
with the data tab
ok and let's get started so the
difference has statistics  the task of checking
hypotheses in order to
check hypotheses, hypotheses tests are required,
for example, the perpetrator or the
correlation analysis example of a
hypothesis is men in austria earn
more than women in the same job
so let me put the hypothesis on
men in austria earning more in the
same shop  as women and m
With the help of a hypothesis test, I would
now like to check whether this is correct.
You now need a hypothesis test.
I need a hypothesis is
whenever I
want to say something about the population with a random sample,
so I want to say about the population
that men earn more in
Austria  earn as the women for
this i would have to ask all men
and all women from all over austria
how much they
earn because that is unrealistic
i need a sample and with the
help of this sample i would like to
make a statement about the totality let's
take a
look  Now look
at everything graphically
so I have a population, for
example all men and women from
all over Austria from this
population I now see a
sample a sample relationship
I would like to describe only this sample
I would use descriptive
statistics such as mean
value or variance but I would like  te yes make a
statement about the population
so i use this sample and
with the help of a hypothesis test
i then conclude on the population
the goal of hypotheses test what is that
the goal is to use random
samples to draw up hypotheses about the
population or the population
so check again i have a sample
and with the help of this sample and
in the hypothesis test i want to
check a statement about the population
ok where can i find the hypothesis and
the hypothesis test right at the
top of the research process i first have to
define the topic based on that
topic, a question is then written
down from the question
, a precisely formulated
hypothesis about the population can then
be
derived based on the hypothesis,
a suitable hypothesis test is then sought
that can check the hypothesis exactly, of course, in order
to check the hypothesis, I need
a  Also the data that is
used for the grandfather's theses.
The data is also about
the random sample that was drawn from the
population that I
want to check and at the end I come
to the conclusion that what is
a
hypothesis?  it is therefore an
assumption about the causal relationships
between variables it is important that there are
always two hypotheses that are
exactly opposite or
claim exactly the opposite these
opposing hypotheses are called 0 and
alternative with precise what
is the difference between the 0 and
the alternative  hypothesis the new
hypothesis assumes that
there is no difference between two or more groups
with regard to a specific
characteristic, for example the
salary of men and women
does not differ in austria
there is no difference that there is an
alternative to this
assumes that there is  one and  there is a difference
between two or more groups
so coming back to the example
the salary of men and women
differs in austria so
the new hypothesis says there is no
difference in salary and the
alternative about low says there is
a difference in salary  ok and what
types of hypotheses are there with
hypotheses, a distinction is made between
difference and connection theses
as well as directed and undirected
hypotheses with difference and connection
hypotheses, a distinction is made
that one then whether different
groups are distinguished or whether
the connection or the correlation
between variables should be checked
check in one case there is
a difference to different
groups, e.g. in men and women
in the other case check whether
there is a connection or a
correlation between variables, for
example hp of a car and
average fuel consumption per
kilometer  r in the case of directed and
redirected hypotheses, a distinction is made as to
whether a difference
relationship is to be
determined or whether the direction is also
of interest so i would just like to
say there is a difference between
the salary of men and women or
i would also like to say in  which direction
or
who has the hearing and value the lower
salary so let's take a closer look at the
difference and connection
hypotheses check difference hypotheses whether there is a
difference between two or more
groups, for example the group of
men earn more than the group of
women or smokers have a higher
heart attack risk than non-
smokers here the group of smokers is compared with the
group of non-smokers so
there is always a categorical variable
such as here the gender which
then has the group men and the
group women or in the  second
example of the smoker st  atus where there are
smokers and non-smokers and
at least one originally scaled variable
in this case it is the salary and in the
other case the risk of heart attack is
in percent
in contrast to this, so
check related hypotheses whether there is
a connection or correlation between
at least two variables, e.g  the
taller a person is, the heavier it
is or the more hp a car has,
the higher the consumption as can be seen in
this example,
related hypotheses on the shape the
more the higher the carriers, i.e. in the
case of related hypotheses,
variables are compared i.e. in  the case
i compare the variable height
and weight the variable weight and
a person in the second example
i compare the variable hp and two
variables consumption of a car
ok now we come to the directed below
directed hypothesis undirected
hypotheses check if there is a connection
or a difference
so yeah  depending on whether I have a connection too
small a difference to the thesis
it doesn't matter in which direction
this connection or the difference goes
first example there is a
difference between the salary of
men and women
here the only question is whether there is a
difference but it is  not
specified which salary is higher, whether that of
women or men or in the
second example there is
a connection between height and
weight so it is only asked
whether there is a connection between
height and weight but it is
not asked whether this is positive or
negative  is so it is not
asked whether an increased body height is accompanied by
an increased body
weight first its difference hypothesis
so i have two groups and
I just want to know if there is a
difference in the peeps but
not which group has the higher earnings
the lower value second  example
is a connection hypothesis
i would like to know if there is
a connection or a coalition between
height and weight
but i don't want to know if this is
positive or negative in contrast
to that the directed hypothesis
the directed hypothesis also indicates
the direction of the connection or
the coalition or just  the
difference if it is a
difference to the thesis is quite
simple as in the example above men
earn more than women so here
I have the statement I want to check whether
men really earn more than women
or in the case of the related
hypothesis the more hp a car has  the
higher the consumption so here
i have indicated a direction again
i say there is a
positive connection between the hp number and
the consumption and i would like to test
it so we have
gone through the different types of hypotheses and
now we come to the next one  topic
another very important
topic related to hyp  Theses and hypotheses test,
the probability of error is almost very
important to understand is that hypotheses
can only be determined with a certain probability of
error or hypotheses
can only
be accepted or
rejected with a certain probability, so with a
hypothesis test I can never say
that  it is 100 percent the case that
men earn more than women in the
same job i can only
say with a certain degree of probability
how is it so in the end i have
my population from this
population a random sample
for the grandpa theses test
could be made, for example  now just
draw two random points sample 1 and
sample 2 i think it will now
be clear to everyone that sample 1 and sample
2 really differ, so sample 1 will have
a minimal deviation from sample
two and that is exactly how both samples will differ
from the population e
so each sample that is considered or
with each sample that I
consider slightly different statements are made
about the basic
total in the worst case a
sample is drawn that coincidentally
deviates very strongly from the
total and there is an incorrect statement about
the total  met
therefore there is the so-called push
agreement which indicates how likely
it is allowed to say that a
hypothesis is only correct or incorrect
here we only want to go into that a
little more closely
let's come back to the significance or
the probability of error
so let's come first  for a
simple explanation, it is not quite
correct for this, so with the help of a
hypothesis test, it is now possible to
calculate how likely it is that
the sample is at a distance from the
population, so the hypothesis test
can say, if I have a sample,
how likely it is that  this
st  i sample really comes from the population
or not
or if the two groups
compare the same can test the prostheses
we say how likely is
it that these two groups come from the
same population
ok now we come to the slightly
more complicated explanation which is correct for this
with help  of the hypothesis
test it is now possible to calculate
how likely it is
to get a result that is at least as
inconsistent with the null thesis as
the result obtained assuming that
the new hypothesis is almost that to give
there it was a bit complicated
so let's see  just look
at this with an example so let's say we
have the population here and we
compare the height or
we look at the height let's say
the
average height in the population is 1 meter 62
which of course we don't actually
know
now we see one  sample
and receive i  n this sample has a
body height of 1 meter 70 now
we want to know whether this sample
really comes from the population and that
is purely coincidental is that the
body size of the sample deviates from the population by exactly
eight centimeters
or whether the
sample is not from a large one  different
population city so the question is
how likely is it that from
the population there is a random sample
that does not drop more than eight centimeters from the
population so every
time I
get a random sample from the population
I get another one in the random sample
different value for height
so i take the first sample
get out 1 meter 65 you the second
sample i get it 155
now i just took a
sample where the height is 1 meter
70 so there is a 1.8 cm difference
between the height of the
population  and the sample
now the question is w  how likely is it
at all that if i get a
sample 2
that there will be a sample
whose body size deviates by more than 8 cm
and that is just as accurate that is the
probability so is the value of the
error probability or
the significant level so how
likely is it that
draw a random sample
from the population that deviates by more than eight centimeters from the
population ok,
so we come to the question when
will a hypothesis be rejected
we have just gone through the fact that
you can never say with 100 percent whether the
hypothesis is now accepted or
rejected  can
now be of course then the
question arises when do you know that so when
is it improbable enough and the
grades so that you can reject the new hypothesis
here it is introduced into the finance
or also the alpha
where called how kams or
cypher level is  just exactly the value
or
the percentage from which one  the new
hypothesis discards it is important that the
significant level is always determined before the
investigation and may not
be changed afterwards in
order to still obtain the desired
result and in order to
obtain a certain degree of
comparability when the publication is opened, that
the finances are usually 5 or 1
percent  So at a significant
level of 1 percent one speaks of
highly significant at 5 percent
of significant and of greater than of
not significant birth theses test calculated in this way
and the result is the null
hypothesis is only four percent, so the
significance level is 4 then four
percent  i can assume that
or land if the hypothesis is
significant let's now come to a small example of
the significance level and the p value
the h0 the new hypothesis is
men and women in
austria do not differ in terms of their average monthly net income
check
a significant level of 5
percent is set and a survey of
600 women and 600 men is
asked about their salary an
independent test is used to test this
hypothesis
the p value for the independent test
is 0.04 the ph value is 04  therefore
smaller than the specified
significant level of 0.05 thus
the new hypothesis is rejected
so on the basis of the data collected
we have sufficient evidence that there
is a statistically significant
difference in the average monthly
net income of men and women in
austria as and now as
promised  a small teaser we could
easily calculate a hypothesis test directly in the web browser for
this
you first open date up for this
you simply go to datatec de then click
on the statistics calculator and could
then insert your data here at the top or
you can use the example data sets from for the first time
thieves are
invited in this below  r this
wide tsg square and hannover
you can test all the differences super theses
you want to test a connection
about the thesis you can come up with correlations here
let’s just start
with the case, for example,
say we would like to say we have now
made a sample first
very  small sample but it is
only an example and you want to
compare the income with the gender
so you have grouped your data up here
you can see the
list of the variables below
you have the disposal now i just click on
income and gender and tape
you calculate one right here
independent test from the below I
then see the results for the calculated
test I can also distinguish whether I
want to calculate a parametric test or a non-parametric test click on the non-
parametric one with which one calculates it with nude
I now want to calculate a
coherent hypothesis  click  ke
i just click on correlation let's
say i want to know if there is
a connection between income
and age i just select
income age and they will
then get my
correlation analysis calculated right away in the browser would
you like to know more detailed information on how
i calculate a correlation or  away
center operation or what a perpetrator
square rest or nova just have a
look at the other videos there it
is explained a little more precisely
I hope you liked the video
and we'll see you next time